so Crystal Visa is a retailing Tycoon
from South Africa and what makes it
interesting is he was on the Forbes
billionaires list in our list of richest
Africans up until 2018 and then this
huge Enron like accounting Scandal
happened at his major asset which is
called steinhoff International that
knocked him off the billionaires list
starting in March of 2018 and now he's
back on the list Visa was worth 5.6
billion dollars in early 2017 by the
time this accounting Scandal was
revealed in the end of 2017 in December
2017 the shares of steinup fell like 90
I mean he lost almost all the value so
Lisa's Fortune fell first down to like
1.1 billion dollars and then he fell off
the list altogether by March of 2018. so
the startup was kind of interesting it
it was founded by a German who was
building furniture and he was sourcing
from East Germany this is when the wall
was still up between East and West
Germany and resourcing for East Germany
and selling to all over and then he
heard that a lot of wood was growing in
South Africa so he went to South Africa
to see if he could get the supplies for
furniture with him there and then he
opened he got into doing Furniture
retail in South Africa and so there was
a German Billionaire Bruno steinhoff
also tied to this company with steinhoff
kept its European operations and that's
where most of the fraud allegedly was
happening so Visa was the chairman of
steinhoff not the CEO an outside
forensic audit by pricewaterhouse PWC
found that he was not involved in the
accounting fraud at all
since he came in you know after it had
been going on for years the person who's
going to be tried apparently in Germany
reportedly in Germany in April is the
former CEO this guy Marcus yusta and he
apparently organized most of the fraud
according to what I've read most of it
happened in the European arm of this
company so the thing that kind of sticks
to my brain is I read this really
interesting book called steinheist which
is about the accounting fraud at
steinhoff and it points out that in 2007
an analyst at the South African arm of
of JPMorgan put out a 56-page report
highlighting the accounting issues and
questions and concerns about
transactions with steinhoff and then two
years later in 2009 the book recounts a
meeting that Visa had with another
Analyst at another firm who had a 40
slide presentation detailing his
concerns about shoddy transactions
suspiciously low tax rates all kinds of
things that didn't really add up
and so in a sense you know I feel like
Visa was warned that there was something
amiss with this company but yet six
years after he met with his analyst he
sold his company to steinhoff
anyway that'll mean to say he had it
coming to him but it's sort of
interesting what we choose to pay
attention to and what we choose to
ignore I think when people have
questions it's good to kind of follow
your instincts on these questions and
pay attention to the doubters
so in addition to his settlement with
steinhoff that gives him cash and shares
in the company in pepcor in the clothing
chain he's got a total about 10 of
ShopRite the supermarket chain that's
like a Walmart of south of southern
Africa and he's also about Holdings in a
few other companies one of them is
called Invicta which is listed on the
Johannesburg Stock Exchange and has
investments in China Singapore and the
UK another from trade hold has
industrial businesses in South Africa
and also commercial property in the UK
and then he's got a Luxembourg listed
firm called brate which owns stakes in
the Virgin Active Health Clubs and in
two South African firms a fashion label
and a consumer goods business most of
those Investments are not nearly as
valuable right now as his ShopRite stake
which is the most valuable thing he owns
right now
a Visa is 81 years old he basically said
that he was shocked that this fraud made
it past all of these Gatekeepers the
internal Auditors the external Auditors
the South African Reserve Bank the
foreign banks that were lending money to
to to steinhoff for somebody whose
Fortune got mostly wiped out in 2018 and
he went through four years of a lawsuit
before settlement you know he seems
probably pretty much at peace with the
world
foreign
[Music]